what's up y'all it's your girl broken
Queen and you can catch me on the
bootleg Kev podcast period
who like cat podcast special guest she's
from Detroit the west side of sorts of
Detroit right yeah Brooklyn Queen is
here what's up y'all
big Brook you're 17. yeah so how long
have you been rapping since I was 11 no
well take it serious at like 11. but
rapping since like five so what like
inspired you to start rapping I just
love music and love entertaining people
okay so was it like you're like going to
talent shows or yeah actually my first
like ever thing on stage I was five at a
school talent show and when I heard
everybody in the crowd just screaming my
name when I got done rapping I was like
this is what I want to do like I want to
be on stage and I want to enter what
were you rapping at five do you remember
um
yeah I do actually wait what is it oh
okay yummy wrap it please it was um
five-year-old bars five-year-old bars
y'all ready for these five-year-old
bikes uh is Brooklyn in the house
without a doubt I'm a little kitty that
you talking about five years old on the
way to the top on a money mission
because I can't be stopped Sun something
ain't gonna know me so put your hands in
the air if you rock it with lmg go
Wrigley got Wrigley I don't know
something like that that's crazy five so
you're like uh yeah you're like a little
Prodigy because you just came you just
did a freestyle one taped it killed it
caught a body real quick caught a body
real quick period and you can't be from
Detroit and not be pretty good at
rapping it's a it's a high level Rap
City yeah for sure I mean you know
Eminem's from there even like the new
guys are crazy uh do you even like does
any
I can't imagine did you grow up
listening to a lot of Eminem
yeah my parents played Eminem So yeah
they did you ever been to a trailer park
no I have not
well no I haven't have you well I have
you've been there I drove through that
[__] for sure I went to Detroit
I said where is Eminem's trailer park
because we're gonna go see that [__] no
I've never seen it maybe I should I feel
like when you're from somewhere you
don't go look at all like the oh for
sure I'm from I'm from Arizona and I've
never been to the Grand Canyon right
it's also like four hours away but like
yeah but yeah no I mean Eminem's trailer
park I've been there you know it was it
was crazy it was a it was a as as
terrible as you'd expect Israel ghetto
[__] up trailer park you know yeah
white white trash ladies [__] water
in there
Trailer Park Lawn and stuff
what about like uh any of the new
Detroit stuff any of that stuff
influence you you obviously got a dope
uh up Dej Loaf is a legend out of the
city cash doll uh you know there's
there's a lot of dope females who have
came from the city yeah I love them all
and one thing I love about them the most
is their hustle like they didn't take no
for an answer and they just kept going
and did what they needed to do do you
feel like
um being young you I mean you kind of
are getting like a head start on a lot
of people in terms of kind of going
through like music industry [__] before
you're 18 you uh you just signed with uh
a good friend brother Uncle of mine
Steve Lobel yes you're the first artist
on Lobel music group yes I am which is
in conjunction with uh Def Jam so shout
out to Steve yep big deal did you know
who Steve Lobel was like like how long
have you known about Steve how long have
I known about him
what
since a little bit before I met him so
when you met him or did it did you
because you know lobel's a lot yeah like
he hit you no I've known about like hit
you with that aggressive Lobel energy no
I've known about his history like
um and the people he's worked with for
sure so yeah because he told you any
cool Bone Thugs-N-Harmony stories yet
yeah he showed me the picture yeah he's
got a lot of have you been to his house
yet no he I don't know if he still has
the purple couches you might be able to
tell me he's got these purple couches at
his house they're crazy
um but yeah what what for you like
because you have a huge social media
follower got over a million followers
how did you amass that following just
through music or were you going viral on
Tick Tock or
um I think it was just from me being
like a kid star and everybody like
followed me because I first went viral
on YouTube for like my first two songs
that I put out seriously okay and
they're over like 70 million views now
um so I feel like that's what people
know me from and then I grew up and
they're like oh where's Brooklyn they
follow me and then I feel like people
just like me because of the stuff I post
damn 70 million views how old were you
when when that happened uh 12. Jesus
yeah shout out to you thank you that
sounds like a gold plaque or something
close right that might be that might be
our like did you put that out there like
this like distribution services yeah
that sounds like you might you might
need to get a little certification 70
million views is a lot yeah
um has there been anybody on the music
side that is kind of like uh you know
been a mentor for you or somebody who's
giving you advice somebody who's you
know maybe just kind of taking a liken
to you and giving you some free game
um
probably the owner of BNB
shop BNB
partnership with lmg don't play with
this
um yeah probably peanut he's the owner
of the label
I've I would say he's yeah him
that's what I feel
you know what's crazy is like there's
another girl who's kind of had a similar
come up a lotto was like a she kind of
was like a kid star yeah and we see all
these videos of her like doing challenge
shows and [__] like have you like kind
of taken any notes and kind of just from
afar watch what she's doing because
she's kind of done a really good job of
like successfully transitioning yeah
from being a kid and then like being an
adult artist that we respect as an emcee
and yeah I feel like that's what that's
how I can kind of relate to her and
that's what I look at her for like she
was such
she's on the rap game and she was like
this kid
um and it was hard for her to go into
the adult Lane when she was getting
older right and I feel like that's the
situation I'm I'm in now I'm trying to
everybody's looking at me as like I'm
just this little girl I'm gonna be 18
y'all let me merge over into being you
know in the teens getting all yeah you
could join the military now uh yeah
how about that what else can you do at
18 you can buy cigarettes no you can't
oh they changed the law actually and you
used to be able to buy Michigan yeah you
used to be able to buy like
I've never smoked so I don't I yeah I
just as a kid it was like okay I'm 18 I
can go to the porno store and I can go
to the damn liquor store and I can get
cigarettes yeah no they changed a lot I
bought cigarettes on my 18th birthday
just to buy them and then I gave them to
my dad okay he smoked I'm like look I
can go to the store now and buy you
cigarettes look at this isn't this nice
you don't have to get your ass up and go
to the store now and go for you right
um for you like uh
how are you constructing like are you
working on Singles body of work an album
like what are you working on right now
um
a whole bunch of singles okay and if we
decide to
to one of them then that's what's gonna
happen but lately I've just been
dropping singles that's dope uh any
features in the works
um in the works of course I just did a
song with Bay vanilla you know yeah from
Detroit I just did a song with they
um I have a song with Yanni she's over
there on the couch shout out to be
Johnny on the couch
um we make songs together and we made a
song called receipts and it did a
million views in a week wow YouTube
stuff yeah well now you got Mr Steve in
your corner he's going he's gonna pick
up that phone you're gonna get some big
features yeah let's do it I'm right here
for sure you got to work with Scott
Storch now okay have you met Scott
storchette no very talented guy he's a
uh well you know who Scott Storch is
yeah yeah one of the greatest producers
of all time
anybody
um for you like uh in Detroit that you
kind of grew up kind of idolizing was
there anybody or were you like just a
rap fan in general because you know like
I feel like somebody like cashed off
somebody who like in the last 10 years
if you've been like kind of taking this
serious in the last decade Castro's kind
of been like
she's like the [__]
she's like the biggie uh Detroit low-key
like I know she's a girl and [__] but
she's so I think she's the biggest I
think she's I think over the last 10
years she's like the hardest rap like
she's like the hardest female yet no I
just think period oh period the last 10
years okay she's been so consistent I
love cash doll yeah
um
I mean I love everybody in Detroit
but music wise look up to like watched
them and like yeah you know what I'm
saying
nobody really uh I mean I love Dej Loaf
they just I love most influential women
ever yeah how she she was just a hood
girl blew up off a try me and then she
crossed over into the mainstream Lane
and now she's going crazy she's super
going crazy yeah what's homeschool like
do you just go like log into a laptop
every day it's so boring you just log
into a laptop yeah do your work um you
gotta get your get your points or
whatever and move up to graduate I'm
ready to get it over with so I could you
hey have you tried to have artificial
intelligence do your homework yet like
chat gbt no they it'll do it for you
really yeah like if you need an essay
written
you just go to chat GPT okay let me type
that and you literally will tell you
could tell tell it what the essay is
about and they don't write like the
whole thing for you oh okay yeah I need
that tell your friends how long have you
been at a normal school
um I've been homeschooled since seventh
grade and now I'm senior so oh wow long
time is it hard to have like a you know
like a normal social group as like a
high schooler being kind of famous
um no because I feel like everyone I
grew up with through Elementary and then
to seventh grade I'm still cool with
right and like you know it's I don't
feel like I missed out on no social
nothing I don't think one thing I did
miss out on high school and last time
I'm sad about that y'all but let's say
do you are you sad about that yeah so
I'm very sad there's no prom well like
homecoming somebody did ask me to prom
but like I want a real prom puzzle like
don't just ask me over the phone you
want to take me to prom like what do you
think this is when someone asked you to
prom over the phone yes they said you
want to go to prom no I don't say I hope
you said no no I didn't say anything I
was like um let me think about it no you
better ask me right if you want to take
me to prom you think yeah that's that's
lazy right that's terrible bring me
bring me bring me a barking whoa
that's also not gonna happen we're
talking we're talking about high school
kids here there's no high school kid
pulling up on you with a Birkin listen
there might be some might be some you
might not you might need to get out of
Detroit at least go to yes you know I
don't know if yeah I'll get out of
Detroit yeah
um we'll we'll go down to a Louie bag a
Louie bag is what if it's a fake one but
the thoughts there
if somebody buys me a fake purse yeah
I'm gonna look at them like they're
crazy and literally throw it at them
because we don't ever come up to me like
what do you think you can't afford the
real one but they wanted to get
something nice then don't get it at all
you can give me some shoes or something
would you prefer a real Coach bag
yes I would prefer I love coach okay I
literally have like five Coach bags so I
would rather have Coach bag than a fake
Louis bag for sure the fake stuff's
pretty close now
no I'm I'm just the type of person I
can't wear fake stuff what if you don't
know it's fake
I know it's not because I'm going in
Louis Vuitton buying it like right so
like right now like there's a lot of
rappers who wear fake jewelry because
nobody would ever question that it's
fake yeah I see that but um it's like
you save the money you can put that
money towards like getting yourself here
do you have a car yet yeah what kind of
car is your what's your first car it was
my first car my first car was a Jeep
okay what's your car now Range Rover and
and hopefully I get a yours for my 18th
you're rich no I'm not
I swear I'm not did you ask for a
Lamborghini Urus for your 18th birthday
a Brooklyn gray Lambo years for my
auntie's birthday and I wanted um like
baby pink seats and then I wanted the
calories be baby pink too but that's
doing too much so I see Mom on the couch
over there what does she do
she's got Chrome arts on she's a dragon
she'll be all right she's dragged in
this thing I'm playing let me stop yeah
how did you grow up did you grow up like
pretty privileged or oh no my parents
are from brightmo and I don't know what
that means it's it's one of the worst uh
I feel is one of the it's like the
changes in Detroit okay right Mom X ask
somebody about it you know double
rockers no I don't no no
oh okay I know every rapper in Detroit
you know the Dough Boys are yeah
Doughboy cash out yeah yeah okay so one
of the guys okay yeah uh from some of
the Doughboys are from Brighton just
look up bright Mountain you you'll see
but no I didn't grow up like
privileged I don't no I was normal
it's my normal I guess a Lamborghini
Urus for your birthday though that's a
it's like a quarter what's that 200 at
least 250. yeah you should you know what
you should you know what you should get
instead for your 18th birthday you
should ask for
investment property
in Detroit you can get you can get 10
houses in Detroit for a Lamborghini Urus
and I'll just take the years
[Laughter]
it's a depreciating asset you get Mom to
help run it you guys split the rental
income I'm not sure how hot the Airbnb
Market is in Detroit if we're being
honest but people need places to live
yeah you're right do you uh are you like
a fan of any sports out there all the
teams kind of suck uh don't listen I
love the Pistons now don't try them
they're terrible no they're not that bad
every game I go to they win so that's
good what's up y'all bootleg Kev here
man got to tell you about our new
sponsors at King Palm baby got a shout
out to them and we're welcoming them
into the new family man of course uh we
treat all of our partners at the boole
cat podcast like family shout out to
King Palm man if you all don't know
about King Palm they're the leaders in
the smoking industry when it comes to
their tobacco-free blunt wraps no
nicotine no tobacco just good old leaves
all right yeah that's right um and look
their product that I love are these
right here now these right here are the
pre-rolled tips you just stuff them with
your your herb your cannabi that you get
from a Hardin and uh
they got these terpene and flu infused
uh tips now what they are is you put
your wheat in there all right you hit
the [__] little pinch on that thing
and you could just burst the flavor now
these are the red reins which is like an
energy drink flavor obviously they got
the Strawberry Shortcake which is also
gas now this is what's dope too there's
just so many lines of these rolls uh
shout out to the leaf tubes you can get
these blueberry these big blue grape
Fusion joints so much you can get man so
many products uh check out your local
7-Eleven your local smoke shop all that
but you could also go to kingpom.com
right now and get everything online
delivered right to your door for half
off 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg that's right shout out to King
Palm man we're talking about essential
smoking uh when it comes to like just
getting that Clean Smoke it's not too
harsh or organic you ain't putting
nothing crazy in your lungs you know
what I'm saying shout out to King pong
no tobacco no nicotine just straight
look and I gotta shout them out too
because
can we take just take a good look at
this
you know we got multiple sized King Palm
hitters over here
I think right there is like a goddamn
Jesus
that's a [__] boy right there you
know what I mean shout out to King Palm
that's a king pong Leaf right there
stuff with some fire some fire all right
so look right now you're going to want
to go to uh kingpom.com uh use that
promo code bootleg get half off whatever
you need smoking accessories Leafs some
of these awesome uh pre-rolls that they
have that you just stuff your stuff in
stuff your stuff in you know what I mean
um kingpom.com 7-Eleven your local smoke
shop all that make sure you follow them
online at King Palm and check them out
speaking of stuff that you're stuffing
shout out to my bookie man my bookie you
already know mybookie.ag I'm riding with
the Phoenix Suns God damn it them Sons
going all the way uh if you are like me
and you like to uh you know put a
friendly wager on some sports
which I do a lot I've been using my
bookie for about 10 years now uh you can
go do the same thing right now now this
is what's dope about my book you go to
mybookie.ag it's the online sports book
not only is it an online sports book
they got the Blackjack they got the
whole Casino situation craps roulette
whatever you're into you could play it
right at mybookie.ag and if you use the
promo code bootleg when you sign up
bootleg you'll see it down below
[Music]
when you sign up you'll get that first
deposit bonus now get a new account
mybookie.ag when you sign up bootleg is
the promo code first deposit bonus up to
a thousand dollars you put in money they
give you money it's that simple all
right there's so many ways you can win
money of course they got NHL right now
the playoffs are happening in hockey if
you're from [__] Canada and you care
about a terrible boring sport also
basketball NBA playoffs are booming
right now put all the money on the
future for the sunset with a
championship thank me later I got Sons
versus Celtics in the uh um finals also
baseball
another atrociously boring sport but a
great sport to gamble on all right so
what you're going to want to do go to
mybookie.ag use that promo code bootleg
right now and get uh your first deposit
bonus unlocked speaking of unlocked
unlock your [__]
go to bluetooth.com right now
it is summertime if you're dealing with
elect erectile dysfunction Ed if you
will maybe you got stress at work maybe
you're tired of looking at the same
chick
maybe you just need a little pep in your
step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of Bluetooth for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discrete
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits
and uh it has the same active ingredient
as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that went over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it I promise you that uh
Bluetooth also is uh incredible because
not only does it come in the blue
chewable flavor with the same active
ingredient as vibrancy Alice but it also
has a mint chewable flavor which is the
same active ingredient as Levitra all
right all this if you're questioning I
don't know I don't want to spend no
money on does this [__] work look yes it
works and you don't have to spend money
if you use the promo code bootleg at
bluetooth.com because it's going to get
delivered right to your house they're
going to give you a month's supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars
shipping that's it the bluetooth's come
into your house no awkward doctor's
appointments
no awkward doctor's visits it's all
online
bluetooth.com thank me later thank me
later let's get back to the interview
when you say not that bad
the Detroit Pistons are an atrocious
stop you can't down they play in the in
the five dollar hot and ready pizza
Arena yeah by the way have you seen it
do they do art if you go to the Little
Caesars Arena are the pizzas five bucks
in there no they're more
they're more yeah that's [__] yeah
if I were to go to a Little Caesars
Arena I expect the prices to be
consistent and I expect the pizza to be
hot and ready everywhere yeah Little
Caesars is a Detroit company right yes
it's a good you know it's a [__]
staple yeah I saw a Little Caesars even
though I don't eat the pizza I only eat
the pepperoni bread or the breadsticks
y'all need to fix have you met the
Detroit dust guy
Detroit does the urban survival dude
this is like the guy who dresses like a
cop and he's got the people oh my gosh
yes I
you met him yeah he's like a I went over
there he [__] beat my ass really yeah
yeah he didn't touch me see I wouldn't
like that
he's he's legit I wouldn't let that
slide yeah do you what do you think is
the biggest misconception about Detroit
um
everybody thinks it's just such a bad
place right like
they think you come to Detroit like
everybody's like oh my God how does it
feel growing up in Detroit normal how
does it feel growing up in Atlanta like
it's the same thing it was great um I
mean it's normal to me everybody thinks
like if you come to Detroit you're gonna
get robbed or I mean you can get robbed
anywhere you get robbed anywhere like
you know how many people are getting
robbed in Beverly Hills right now I was
gonna say people think the same thing
about Cali but like everyone's getting
robbed out in L.A right now I'm like not
everybody just the [__] who walk
around with a bunch of jewelry on their
neck right no but for real I mean
Detroit it's normal to me I feel like
you can get robbed anywhere you can get
killed you know what else is normal
about the Detroit uh it the food is very
normal
normal yeah
it's not great it's just normal it is
great come to my house you're you're
gonna be good no listen I went to a
bunch of coneys searching for you know
the Mystique of the Detroit Coney and it
was just a lot of normal food but what
did you get
I got some Coney I got some fries I got
a cheesecake I got a burger I got a
patty melt I got what no uh so you can't
go to Coney Island and order the normal
things you would get everywhere else in
the world so what do I order
boom go in get you some chili fries or
you can get some chili cheese fries put
some mustard on them boom so good uh
What else corned beef egg rolls okay now
that sounds like not normal corned beef
egg rolls with the pink sauce from Nikki
D's get the pink salad dressing see I
went to Nikki D's
you didn't order the right thing you
didn't order the right thing it's the
first place I went to we're it's a one
by the place their nickname truth right
and it's kind of diagonally across the
street right that [__] was weak
no it's not
it's not telling you you ordered
something right Cyrus what'd you get
well you got he got an omelette an
omelet he's he's a veggie listen you got
to get an omelet put chili on top with
feta on top of that and then you're yeah
you're good I think the best food we had
out there was in the food court at the
MGM Grand really are you serious
no it was some noodles y'all are going
to the wrong places have you been abused
um we went to a burger place that had
deep fried Doritos
Doritos deep fried stuffed Doritos it
was all right yeah it wasn't bad
uh Pizza okay pizza cat pizza cat you
ought to go to pizza cat you gotta go to
pizza cat views
um uh baby Tron took us to this fake
raising canes and it was really good it
was called like Uncle Joe's or Uncle
somebody's or cups I know what you're
talking about it was super good it was
better than Raising Canes really oh my
God it was amazing and they had shrimp
so they had chicken and shrimp oh yeah
um y'all go to you ever have raisins yes
I love canes it is good ever planned on
moving out of Detroit
um well I kind of did halfway I mean I
still live there and then I live in L.A
so oh you live here too I go back and
forth yeah yeah so which which place are
you do you feel like you're safer at
because I felt a lot more safer in
Detroit I feel safer in Detroit too
y'all don't know what I've been through
out here with these crazy people on the
street I would never say I was hanging
out of the tree I saw no homeless I mean
I saw a few homeless people but it was
not like L.A no when I tell you
literally I've been attacked in La
somebody literally they swarmed our car
in a 7-Eleven parking lot and then they
was hanging on our windshield while we
were driving the Range Rover no no no no
this was somebody's uh somebody else's
car
but like they were hanging on the
windshield fentanyl people
I don't know what they were I don't know
they were crazy I don't know if they
were homeless you gotta stay out of
downtown you know people just hang out
in the I wasn't even in downtown it was
in Hollywood yeah Hollywood's crazy I
just said stay in the valley
yeah
that was crazy in Hollywood yeah you're
too bougie for Hollywood I'm not boozy
y'all you want a Lamborghini Urus for
your birthday that's wild that's not
bougie you know I mean people want a
Lambo truck that's not
I mean want but I feel like you're gonna
get it yeah I feel like I have a good
chance that I feel like I'm gonna get it
uh when is uh you you just talked about
your new record with her on the couch
but uh how many new songs are ready to
go and when is the music dropping
like 20 songs ready to go okay and music
is dropping very very very soon I just
posted um a sneak peek of my new song
back that ish up don't know which day
I'm gonna drop it yet but the video is
ready the song's ready everything's
ready to go nice are you uh are you
dating
am I dating I'm single as a pringle okay
and ready to mingle no don't say that
I'm not ready to make your mom a heart
attack over there
no I'm single as a pringle
I've dated before but you should stay
single yeah it's time to focus on your
career right now yeah you know what I
mean yeah and then like one day
then like when you have like a bunch of
plaques on the wall when you're when
your house looks like Steve lobel's
living room okay that's when you can
settle down you know but live your life
get to 30. yeah I don't want to be tied
down to nobody like you're not going to
be telling me what I can and can do
who's your favorite rappers right now oh
Lotto making a stallion um
um
uh uh city girls of course
I didn't say female rappers but if all
your favorite rappers are female that's
great too okay Tupac
okay
um
uh uh uh a little baby of course do you
listen to NBA young boy yes I love
zombie thanks for reminding me I'm just
wondering because I feel like every 17
year old in the world is like that's all
they listen to is that and you eat
and who yeet
who is that you don't know about yeet
now he's popping right now I don't know
who that is he's got the Minion song The
what he always has a push iced tea on
he's like the like he look I think he's
Mexican he's [__] huge right now
no he's I don't know where you don't
know about ye no you have to show me
oh my God I go crazy for this kid
like you go to a yeet show it's just a
bunch of Dusty white chicks with beat
down forces
about it in l
Anella forces and nobody will say
nothing but if you wear some forces like
that
like that they're gonna tell you park
them right there and you know you know
how to park forces I don't literally if
somebody be like oh you need to park
those you're supposed to take your
forces off and just leave them there
because they're that bad what if you
don't have socks on did you just leave
before this is there also if you don't
have socks on and you're wearing shoes
you're a [__] scoundrel what's up
guys hey uh if you are watching this and
it's April 20th 4 20
I'm gonna be hanging out at hardean
today
but that's right put the flyer up The
Rock
I'll be at hardeen um hanging out all
day today
um the craziest most just luxurious
illest dispensary in the world located
right in Las Vegas Nevada now Hardy in
Las Vegas they are our family they'd
sponsor the podcast I love those guys
dearly and when I say that it is the
best place I've ever walked into to buy
premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
to put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so uh what y'all need to
do is go follow them online hardeen
underscore Las Vegas follow them on the
gram
we got a lot of dope stuff in the works
they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're gonna be doing a
lot of content in Vegas
live from hardeen they also just dropped
a [__] tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope flag gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
get that hard eating whiff smells
amazing so look make sure you go to
hardine uh if you're in Vegas get in
that Uber get in that cab as soon as you
touch down say take me to hardine the
taxi drivers the Ubi drivers they know
exactly where it is because it's the
hottest spot in Vegas they go take you
straight there you're gonna tell them I
sent you they're going to get you
situated real nicely all right Harding
underscore Las Vegas go show them some
love go to hardinglasvegas.com gotta
give a shout out oh geez my dogs had Odd
Socks baby they've been [__] with us
from day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butthead socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead
drawski's bro
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
oddsoxofficial.com my first uh
suggestion would be get you a pair or a
pack of the Odd Socks Basics the black
and the whites those are my go-to's and
then you gotta [__] with some of these
Big Lebowski socks
and they just got Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bruh what are we talking about
go to oddsoxofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg say 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview
gotta stink something crazy
oh no socks not even a little invisible
anklets
songs
you gotta stop hanging out with her
[__] the forces she got some stank ass
feet
she's gonna have to park her hooves
the bunions
Jesus
uh do you have like a rap crew like that
like you're forming is this a part of
your crew this girl like are you guys
yeah she's a part of my crew do you guys
have a name like you know there's like a
Wu-Tang Clan there's like Dip set no
we're not like a a group we're like
individual people but I mean you could
just call us bad [__] I guess
I can't call you that you're not um old
enough to be called that why you're 17.
listen you're a respectable young lady
the bad [__] at the age of I've been a
baby since I was born
that's not true it is that's I always
thought I was bad
well the uh new music's coming soon
uh uh anything else you want to talk
about
um anything you're working on
I'm just working on new music uh like I
said we're going to Vegas today
um yeah it's a great place for a 17 year
old to go do absolutely nothing
you're just gonna go hang out on Friday
go to Fremont Street go to the buffets
um well the pools be off the hook
I mean the pools I guess that you I mean
yeah maybe
but can you get me in a club no I
wouldn't either that's a felony I'm all
about risking someone's liquor license I
own a nightclub what I look like we can
we could just sneak in the back door you
know how many clubs I snuck in the back
door I don't snitch
don't zero the answer is zero
no the clubs in Detroit uh what is it
Club blue you you have to be 18 to get
in wow you have to be 18 to get in they
let me in well I think if you are
performing yeah you're allowed to go in
okay so will you give me a performance
at a club in Vegas so then I can go in
uh I mean I could ask okay
Johnny you ready to go to the club
you got your your guy Steve Lobel Steve
lobela gets you to God in the white
house if you give him enough time okay
he'll sneak you right in and be like yo
Barak this is my new artist right here
shout out to my guy Maniac Lobel man hey
appreciate you pulling up Brooklyn Queen
go uh follow her Brooklyn Queen 03 yes
Brooklyn Queen 03. even though you were
born in 05. yep
the year I graduated high school yeah
class of 05. wait so when you graduated
you had a kid I had a kid when I was 17.
okay so I already well my baby's mom was
pregnant when I graduated okay yeah
cool are you doing you're over here
doing math you're like wait a minute you
said your son was my age yeah so you had
a kid in high school you were a bad kid
in high school that's not bad yeah
well nonetheless back in y'all's day
that's not bad
oh five babies are in the building
period go follower Brooklyn Queen 03 new
music on the way and uh let's get your
friend a [__] some Odd Socks yeah
Yanni
you need some socks we got to get her
some Odd Socks because now that you said
it it does smell kind of crazy in here
thank you boom